in this segment we will discuss the
multinomial model and the multinomial
probabilities which are at nice
generalization of the binomial
probabilities the setting is as follows
we're dealing with balls and balls come
in two different colors there are our
possible different colors we pick a ball
at random and when we do that there is a
certain probability P I that the ball
that we picked has the eighth color now
we repeat this process and times
independently each time we get a ball
that has a random color and we're
interested in the following kind of
question somebody fixes for us certain
numbers and 1 & 2 up to n R that adapt
when and asks us what is the probability
that when you carry out the experiment
you get exactly n1 balls of the first
color exactly and two balls of the
second color and so on so the numbers n
1 & 2 and up to n R are fixed given
numbers for a particular choice of those
numbers we want to calculate this
probability now of course this is a more
general model doesn't necessarily deal
with balls of different colors for
example we might have an experiment that
gives us random numbers where the
numbers range from 1 up to R and at each
time we get a random number with
probability P I we get a number which is
equal to I so we could use this to model
die rolls for example and there is
actually a special case of this problem
which should be familiar suppose that we
have only two colors and instead of
thinking of colors let us think of the
two possibilities as being heads or
tails and we can make the following
analogy somebody gives us numbers n1 and
n2 that add up to end and we're
interested in the probability that we
get n1 of the first color and n2 of the
second color well we could think of this
as a setting in which were asking for
the probability that we obtain K heads
and n minus K tails so the question of
what is the probability that we obtain K
heads and n minus K tails ifs of the
same kind ask what is the probability
that we get n1 of the first color and n2
of the second color
now if heads have a probability P of
occurring and tails has a probability of
1 minus P of occurring then we would
have the following analogy the
probability of obtaining the first color
which correspond to heads that would be
equal to P the probability of obtaining
the second color which correspond to
tails this would be 1 minus P now the
probability of obtaining K heads in
those n independent trials we know what
it is by the binomial probabilities it
is n choose K times P to the K times 1
minus P to the power n minus K now we
can translate this answer to the
multinomial case where we're dealing
with colors and we do these
substitutions so n choose K is n
factorial divided by K factorial in this
case K is the same as and 1 so we get an
N 1 factorial and then we are going to
have here n minus K factorial but n
minus K corresponds to n 2 so here we
get an N 2 factorial and then P
corresponds to P 1 and P 2 corresponds
to 1 minus P so we get here P 1 times P
2 and the power and minus K again by
analogy is n 2 so this is the form of
the multinomial probabilities for the
special case where we're dealing with
two colors let us now look at the
general case let us start with an
example to be concrete
suppose that the number of colors is
equal
three and that we're going to pick n
equal to seven balls we carry out the
experiments and we might obtain an
outcome which would be a sequence of
this type so the first ball had the
color one the second ball had the first
color the third ball had the third color
the fourth ball had the first color and
so on and suppose that this was the
outcome
one way of summarizing what happened in
this outcome would be to say that we had
four once we had two twos and we had one
three we could say that this is the type
of the outcome it's of type four to one
but is we obtained for of the first
color two of the second color and one of
the third color this is one possible
outcome what is the probability of
obtaining this particular outcome the
probability of obtaining this particular
outcome is using independence the
probability that we obtain color one in
the first trial color one in the second
trial color three in the third trial
color one in the fourth trial color tool
in the next trial color two in the next
trial color one in the last trial and we
put all the factors together and we
notice that this is P 1 to the fourth P
two to the second times P 3 it's not a
coincidence that the exponents that we
have up here are exactly the counts that
we have when we specified the type of
this particular outcome generalizing
from this example we realize that the
probability of obtaining a particular
sick
of a certain type that probability is of
this form for each color we have the
probability of that color raised to the
power of how many times that particular
color appears in a sequence so any
particular sequence of this type has
this probability what we're interested
in is to find the total probability of
obtaining some sequence of this type how
can we find this probability well we
will take the probability of each
sequence of this type which is this
match and it's the same for any
particular sequence and multiplied with
the number of sequences of this type so
how many sequences are there of a
certain type let us look back at our
example we had seven trials so let us
number here the different trials and
when I tell you that a particular
sequence was obtained that's the same as
telling you that in this set of trials
we had the first color in this set of
trials the fifth and the sixth trial we
had the second color and in this trial
the third trial we had the third color
this is an alternative way of telling
you what sequence we obtained I tell you
at which trials we had the first color
at witch trials who had the second at
witch trials we had the third but what
do we have here here we have a partition
of the set of numbers from 1 up to 7
into 3 sub sets and the cardinalities of
those subsets are the numbers that
appear here in the type of the
sequence the conclusion is that a
sequence of a certain type is equivalent
or can be alternatively specified by
giving you a partition of the set of
tosses which is the set from 1 up to n
how many trials we've had a partition in
two subsets of certain sizes so this
allows us now to count the number of
sequences of a certain type it's exactly
the same as the number of partitions and
we know what this is and putting
everything together the probability of
obtaining a sequence of a certain type
is equal to the count of how many
sequences do we have of the certain type
which is the same as the number of
partitions of a certain type times the
probability of any particular sequence
of that type that we're interested in so
this is a formula that generalizes the
one that we saw before for the case
where we have only two colors and which
correspond it to the coin tossing
setting and it is a useful model because
you can think of many situations in
which you have repeated trials and at
each trial you obtain one out of a
finite set of possible results there are
are different possible results you
repeat those trials independently and
you may be interested in the question of
how many results of the first kind of
the second kind and so on there will be